well the first thing is that it is it is
the actual making of language the actual
the in the present moment sound that a
person is making and how they're making
that sound
that's where identity lives I think I
don't think it really lives in like if
you took my what I'm saying here and you
transcribed it I don't think that's Anna
deavere Smith but I think that a series
of sounds and movements are Anna deavere
Smith in other words the outward product
of that and you know your your your
languages is close to your breathing
it's close to your heart and usually
what I like to listen for is the time
when somebody says something in an
unusual way
in that usually I talk to people for
about an hour and for example if they're
constantly using upward inflections you
know always speaking up you know
everything they say goes up which
younger people tend to do as I heard a
very accomplished judge say when asked
what advice you could give to young
women lawyers we're trying to make it is
don't do that because what does it say
to the judge if you come forward and say
Your Honor my client is not guilty
sounds like a question right so if
someone's talking all like that what I'm
going to listen for is the time that
they don't do that and that's what I
would start to study as a way of
characterizing them whereas I think a
professional mimic or an impressionist
would pick the thing they do the most
because that's what you and audience
could then identify as that person so an
impressionist doing George Bush is going
to try to find the gestures and the
you know the intonations that he keeps
using over and over again but if I were
to study him
I haven't really I'd look for when he
did something that wasn't what we've
seen
I went to Washington and I interviewed
520 people or more and I was surprised
that I would say of those people the
person Clinton was probably among the
five who had the most musicality in
their language in other words in
Washington I would say you begin to find
less and less expression than you find
in other places because people are very
careful about what they say they're
going to be judged for what they say
they could say the wrong thing to say it
the wrong way and never live it down
so they have as someone said very
eloquently what Thomas Jefferson had
which is that Thomas Jefferson could
never be found in verbal undress and so
I was and so that kind of verbal
dressing makes it harder to find music
in the language I'm trying to find the
time that people start to sing I called
it singing not actually you know
lalalalala but they really start to open
up
rhythmically more than again what's the
text it's more about this singing as I
call it and I was surprised the extent
to which Clinton sang and the other
thing about Clinton that I enjoyed was
that he brought truth to something that
a linguist had actually told me many
years ago when I told her what I was
trying to do that is to say a form of
getting people to sing she had said to
me well I'm going to give you three
questions that can ensure that that that
will happen in the course of an hour if
you only have an hour to talk to people
and the three questions were have you
ever come close to death do you know the
circumstances of your birth and have you
ever been accused of something that you
didn't do now when I first started my
whole process which I call on the road
of search for American character all of
my plays are part of that series
I originally just sat with people who I
met on the streets of New York and
talked to them about whatever they you
know they sold milk I talked about
selling milk or stickball on the street
in one case or being a lifeguard at the
Y I'd sort of talked them about what
they did and then somewhere in the
interview I'd ask those three questions
and lo and behold every time I did
people would start this singing that I'm
talking about so when I finally got an
interview with President Clinton which
wasn't easy and was told that I would
have 10 minutes alone with him in the
Oval Office I knew that I had to have a
question that would cause him to use the
entire ten minutes without me having to
say anything and the question I picked
was a version of one of those three
questions and it was mr. president do
you think you're being treated like a
common criminal which is a version of
have you ever been accused of something
that you didn't do he spoke for 35
minutes and as people you know coming to
the office mr. president you need to
rest your voice now okay bye so I was
really happy to see that something that
I learned you know you know 30 years
before not quite 30 20-some years before
I met him actually was in good stead as
much as like I you know I had
researchers I had everything in the
world to try to find the question I
should ask President Clinton